à qui est le plus fanion qui est le
compagnon est orienté alors moi je
voulais lire facile pour moi qui ai le
plus fan ou non fait j'en hormis les
gens mais c'est sûrement d'accord
hormis si vous êtes ma jument est
cependant je vous adore a vu ce que je
vais continuer une question à qui a la
plus grosse voiture
bah vous aujourd'hui non non non non non
c'est pas germain castano aqua grosse
twingo merci non mais c'est vrai c'est
benjamin castaldi je dirais pas sa
voiture mais il a une grosse voiture
voilà oui ouais maria défaut 2
c'est un malaise je vais là jean
fournier c'est les boules je prends une
boule et interviennent quelques éditions
d'hier entre nick alors attention
présent un chroniqueur présent qui
n'aimerait qui n'amènerait tu jamais en
vacances il n'amènerait tu jamais en
vacances mais il m'a déjà nés chez
benjamin castaldi il pète trop merci
sans kobe dessus non mais benji mais je
suis là d'or mais il pèse beaucoup dans
mes rêves avec ministre soit nommé
récemment patron je vous dis la vérité
non c'est parce que j'ai trouvé c'est
trop mais j'aime beaucoup mes cris tron
et kelly aussi avec les troncs à qui ne
prêteraient tu jamais d'argent de
benjamin castaldi
ça normal on a d'autres
on a notre boulot dakar fait petit s'est
inquiété de la main à qui tu ne donnera
jamais de prime de la boîte à cigares
des marges il adore mais en prime ccc
c'est pas son délire que vous n'avez pas
envie quand j'adorerais très bien qu on
en reparle dans l'air une petite
question
une petite question qui a la plus
mauvaise haleine ce n'est pas me choisir
je peux pas à l'aise je peux pas le dire
je vais l'écrire c'est toi tu vas dire
aux gens pour une autre qui est le plus
radin c'est eux qui est le plus radin
c'est l'action
attila et de leur belle série les voilà
et maxime maximum herrada économe puis
j'ai je connais depuis deux ans va faire
il n'a pas donné un ami inutile qui lui
écrivait un oui mais je le fais que te
des on a envie qu'on a perdu je sais que
c'est quelqu'un qui pète ici ou pas
alors annoncée par jean daniel très
bonne année alors c'est pas plus proche
ou ailleurs ouais donc c'est un peu plus
encore la manche à la nage sur deux mois
ouais bah ouais bon attention quant à la
version 2 ou très banal est exact soit
pas compris qui s'habille le plus mal
c'est isabelle style